here are the seven rules of free speech
in schools one students from first grade
to twelfth can't be punished based on
their political or religious speech as
the Supreme Court said in the Tinker
case it can hardly be argued that
students shed their constitutional
rights at the schoolhouse gate this
protects for instance wearing black
armbands who protest a war distributing
religious messages to classmates between
classes or criticizing a teacher over
lunch two schools can punish speech that
materially disrupt school work for
instance because it prompts fights
that's why lower courts have let schools
ban clothing that displays confederate
flags and in one case even clothing that
displays an American flag on Cinco de
Mayo when that display led to violence
that's a kind of hecklers veto where
threats against the speaker are used by
the government to justify restricting
the speaker rather than the threateners
usually the government can't impose such
a hecklers veto but the rule in schools
seems to be different that may not seem
right to you but I don't make the law I
just make videos about it
schools can also punish students for
using vulgarities or sexual innuendos so
if you do criticize that teacher over
lunch be you know polite about it four
schools can punish speech that seems to
praise drug use and probably also
alcohol use and other crimes at least
when that speech doesn't seem political
that's from Moore's beef Frederick where
the Supreme Court said a school could
suspend a student for holding up a
banner that read bong hits for Jesus yes
this is a real case in fact you can
actually find audio of Supreme Court
Justice Stephen Breyer saying on hits
for Jesus which is completely surreal
so legalize marijuana is probably okay
but marijuana is awesome probably isn't
five you may have the right to speak at
school but you don't have the right to
speak in the school newspaper courts see
the newspaper as the school's own speech
even if students are the ones who write
it the principal has ultimate control
over what goes in the newspaper and can
delete or edit any article for pretty
much any reason six everything said so
far deals with public schools under the
so called state action doctrine the
First Amendment doesn't limit private
schools even ones that get tax breaks or
government funds the first words the
First Amendment are Congress shall make
no law that applies to the federal
government the Fourteenth Amendment
basically says no state shall violate
people's rights that applies the First
Amendment to state and local governments
but the Constitution generally doesn't
constrain private prop
as private landlords private schools or
anyone else that's why when your parents
told you to stop saying rude things at
the dinner table and you asked what
about my First Amendment rights they
said let's talk about the state action
doctrine or at least that's what they
should have said seven it's all
different in California sure everything
is different in California but what I
mean is that everything I've said so far
is the constitutional minimum that all
states must provide some states have
passed laws that provide more
protections to students in California
for instance high school students
generally can't be punished for their
speech even if it provokes other
students into acting disruptively that
generally can't be punished for speech
about drugs or alcohol or even vulgar
speech and public school newspapers are
mostly free from being censored by the
administration student newspapers are
protected in some other states too
indeed in California all the student
speech protections but not the student
newspaper speech protections apply to
private high school students as well but
not in religious high schools so there
you have it political and religious
speech is protected but not disruptive
speech vulgar speech sexual speech or
speech praising drugs also official
school newspapers are the school's own
speech this stuff really only applies to
public schools and of course California
is different that's the law of free
speech in school cobbled together by the
court and a few legislators over the
past 50 years or so this is not legal
advice if this were legal advice it
would be followed by a bill please use
responsibly written by Eugene Bullock
who's an actual real-life First
Amendment law professor at UCLA I'm
Eugene Baalak and I approve this message
you